[Music]
hi everybody my name is Morelli amela
I'll be hosting this fireside chat with
Melissa and Andrew and to start I
actually want to ask you all who are
here today how many of you do I already
have a necessary team in your company
please raise your hand how many of you
are actually started thinking about
starting a new S or a team or hiring for
your own already existing SRE team okay
so you'll be talking here today about
how to start a necessary and also how to
hire a Suri's and other questions okay
nuez oh I do have a few questions that I
will be I starting with but we will have
time for you to to make questions as
well so please start thinking about that
if you've not covered if I don't cover
the questions here please raise your
hand and you're gonna give you the mic
as well okay okay so the first question
I have on here which is probably a
challenging one is how do I know when my
organism sa-18 and so what justifies for
me an S or a team what issues exist and
what are the potential benefits sure so
the question is you know what how do I
know what I need a necessary team and
you and I decided here the time we would
kind of tie would take this this sort of
big company we would take kind of small
company perspective so you get both from
a big company perspective what we're
looking at is you know if you have a
necessary team how do you know when to
make an additional essary team or shard
off to a new org and there's sort of two
things we look at you're looking for
technology and focus that is similar so
I was involved in the creation of GC
psra and we split it off from our
internal tech inference and we did that
because we saw that there is actually a
critical difference between interacting
with external customers and the concerns
that external customers had about how we
handle the Russell is how we handled all
responses that differed from how we did
internal software and trying to combine
the two in one focus just just wasn't
actually giving us the amount of
leadership and with that we needed so
splitting that off helped us service
well you folks much better and allowed
our internal teams to really be able to
focus on what they cared most about
which was the capacity efficiency focus
the other thing to do is to look at your
dev partners you want to have an
organization generally that aligns at
least somewhat with them and when
there's when you have one sort of focus
covering a large depth swath they may
not be getting the kind of partnership
they're looking for so that was the
other thing that we did was we were able
to then just split up our dev vp's
across the two of us and get sort of
better coordination with the dev teams
better depth of knowledge and better
alignment with the business so
the historical like how would you seed
your first essary team from Google's
bases the short answer how many people
have gone from and are currently at from
zero to one asari teams or just about to
go to their first okay so in this
history essary was formed because there
was out of all the broad general
software engineering worlds there were
several people who had self-identified
and kind of clustered around the
production boundary the production
interface they were literally called
production team and it was interesting
because it wasn't the production ops
team or what have you it was the
software engineers most production
curious as it were and I think he was a
very important and I think accidentally
insightful thing that Google did which
was is that we recognized this boundary
and we want to support it so take a look
around
things are curious creatures and they'll
tend adjust
they want to do reason see if you can
encourage and seed may I suggest an SRE
team from the general traditional
engineering side with those most
production with adjacent describe it as
you're looking for the folks who are
more interested in the activities around
the software then ensuring outlines have
code themselves and I suspect this
applies to a bunch of folks here because
you're all here but you know the people
who get really annoyed when you have a
bunch of bugs that are out of date or
you know see ICD pipeline isn't working
right or your pushes keep stalling and
like it's not that you don't like
writing code but you keep being
attracted to solve those problems around
the software not just in the software so
maybe an indicated sign of this is like
we were saying is if you are here how
many of your colleagues at any level
your organization would also like to be
here right now is it more than two you
probably have a nascent essary team
already happening
you should just fund it awesome I think
we started to talk a little bit about
the next question as well so we have two
or three people and plus two people that
want to do this SRA thing
so we have a necessary team it's a
buzzword recently right sree sree
created an SAE team but we're not really
sure what it should be doing so in
reality what is this or a team doing and
then we can either split in the startup
versus B okay so forgive me if I'm a
about this I spend a lot of my time
doing college and industry recruiting
for a series to come to Google so
naturally I'm biased and excited about
this but the way I try to explain the
way the neccesary is it's really like
whether or not you buy into the left
brain right brain sort of thing I'm
going to instead say it's like two
halves of the brain I'll proactive and
reactive right yes of course there's the
carry the pager the react to various
things that the vigilance and the
diligence type type stuff this is all
well and good but there's also this very
much they always be prepared within
reason proportionately you know
proportion the reason sort of way what I
mean is you know having the regular
conversations in your team the disaster
drills the let's think about the best
and worse that could happen type type
stuff so it's an equal balance right you
want to be there at the earliest part of
the design phase in order to be able to
make the subtle improvements from the
experience in the gravitas that you a
necessary has had four years from doing
this sort of thing to influence and make
sure that the error bars on a launch of
something that has been designed you
know X months ago aren't very large
lately the biggest non event of the
summer should be the launch of said
product or project that you were
involved in so I'm looking for folks who
are good engineers but also good reverse
engineers which is something sometimes
we forget
I'm not necessarily saying it should be
a bunch of you know I don't know IT
jockeys who question authority and not
always like to break their alarm clocks
open to figure out how they work
thinking about as people who are
inquisitive people analytical people who
want to understand a system and that can
come from either software engineering
and/or ITN ops right it's it's a
spectrum these are the sorts of things I
look for in the folks that I bring into
a necessary organization and they want
to expand on that
it is dangerously easy to develop a
monoculture in your nest or a team based
on the values of the person who is most
influential which might be the start or
the first badge or the leader whatever
if that person is highly biased towards
very often a reactive stuff you can get
an S or a team that is going to double
down way too much on being excited by
incidents and way too little on long
term planning if the person happens to
actually be like a frustrated software
engineer will be rather writing code but
got told they're not good enough SiC to
be necessary by the way that's terrible
don't do that but you're going to get a
team that is constantly like railing
against wanting to do features on the
product instead of doing automation code
so a really critical thing is to think
through all the different essary is an
incredibly multidisciplinary activity
you need people who are good at deep
software debugging you need people who
are good at understanding distributed
systems you need people who are good
they understand the ways your
infrastructure can go wrong there's so
many different aspects of the person you
get the immediate versus the long-term
the break fix the designs you want as
diverse intellectually a crew as you can
if you're interviewing someone who is
completely unlike you but interested in
it that's a really good sign and
focusing on that when building your team
drawing from us diverse a background and
diverse in every possible way that you
can you will build a much stronger team
at the end because everyone can learn
how to answer a pager but having people
who are interested in the long term
people who are interested in the short
term we have semester E's who like their
most exciting moment is when we declare
a Google right in
and they get to be at command of the
helm of like getting a whole bunch of
people to respond to something like I've
watched those folks I'm not those people
my interest is really on the product
side and how do I make customers as
happy as we possibly can and then I have
some colleagues who are so deep into the
hardware and the optimizations and what
you know what performance can we eke out
of this but all of us together are what
make us are a great anyone over
over-index would be just would not
participating how there's aspect how do
we actually prioritize the activities
that the SRA should be the way for
example should be focusing on emergency
response should be focusing on the
dashboards the monitoring what how's
that conversation like to focus on the
activities that they will be doing I
think it really depends on the size and
the trajectory of the team because a
very well tenured fully fleshed out sort
of team I think we'll have a different
resting set of ratios and also I don't
think that every single person on the s3
team will have the exact same set of
interests so you you afford the luxury
of being able to kind of load balance
from within once you get to a series of
staple engagements around two very
well-known space but still a lot of
change in the velocity of the individual
products and when you start and by the
way I have my own set of opinions on
what the minimum spanning set of essary
is like best accessory into a pilot I've
ever seen is we're gonna hire one person
we're gonna work all of the space that's
called a scapegoat
the engineer and that's how we're doing
your s or York you know what not to do
later but like essentially let's say you
have a new set of people we're all very
new to the role we're trying to kind of
get up to speed there's a lot of like
in front of the treadmill slash People
Mover that may happen but it's how do
you do it I think it's most important
that will afford you the ability to get
to a point like I mentioned previously I
don't know what's how to prioritize the
activities necessary team you'll be
doing I don't have much data what Andrew
said other than to answer a slightly
different aspect of it which is that I
would simply encourage you to make sure
you are actually prioritizing because
it's very easy to not prioritize and to
have the sort of urgent always Trump the
important one of the ways I like to talk
about this is in terms of budgets where
you say ok we are planning on having you
know 20% of our team's energy going
towards working with the devs on new
products 50% of our team's energy going
towards doing automation on the stuff
we've already on-boarded and math 30% of
our team's energy going towards
operational issues and then actually
test that that's true and when it's not
stop and think is this really actually
the thing to do or you just reacting
like I investor a team's tell me they
can't possibly tell their devs that they
cannot spend you know only 20% of their
time on new products I'm like what have
you tried
it actually turns out to work
surprisingly well people understand the
concept budgets they understand I have a
lot of things to do with this is how I'm
prioritizing things so that that's one
of my favorite ways to handle is with
buckets and you talked a little bit
about what I'm going to ask next teams
be there do their relationships with the
devil
in the company I think it's a matter of
mutual respect at all times so for
example here's a couple of antique
patterns I'm gonna come in and here like
the you've got velocity and you got
reliability
they're 180 degrees out of phase with
each other right wrong but okay so
what's the best way to increase our
stability by all the humans stop making
changes right like that is the best way
to quickly reduce yourselves to the
exaggeration of a strictly on the Ox
organization it's amazing how stable
your system is over the winter holidays
exactly just freeze all the time so the
way I like to pitch the value of a sari
to any dev team that I work with is one
be there from day one with you we've got
your back and vice versa
I also want to explain like the way I
talk with my hands a lot I try to make
it maximally orthogonal the relationship
between velocity and stability because
the car that had like a driver's ed
person in the passenger seat like they
had a break right so if your dev
organization receives you as the driver
ed instructor with the brake you're
doing if they perceive you as the weird
person riding shotgun with you that has
an extra accelerator
better I will often looking like that
teams to say how can we go faster I'm
gonna wait the automation I'm gonna late
the safeguard rails to make it so that
we can decode some of the scariness from
this we make things I will go back we
have figure out ways to do experiments
with segments stuff we will many feet
you know one cherry Pepsi I will not
tank the whole release would be able to
march forward and backward on our
features so if you get into a shouting
match if you get into a post-wedding
this is a I'm gonna pointed someone I
know in the audience it's a blame
exercise because they know
it really should be I've saved your butt
several times over and we've made this
faster together you saved each others
butts
I think that's really good if you stay
off from an adversarial relationship
there is no lay in - it's not like you
have to start here together there's a
couple of failure modes I've seen that a
Suri's can take deep offense to and not
realize that it's just the devs not
always thinking things through
probably the prime warmness is just
going off but you said the end is that
Esther days are magical unicorns in
terms of the devs like I've had a dev
say this to me that they couldn't
possibly take on this project and I said
why not they said well we don't know
anything about the code they're like
literally what do you do for a job dude
I mean like we take on code we don't
know all the time so can you and so but
you don't it is easy for an SRE team to
fall into kind of a blame game and
appointing there and say that all the
devs do is throw stuff over the wall you
have to kind of sit down and tell them
when that's happening and say hey like
this isn't ok can we talk about this
decently often when an s decently often
every necessary team evolving out of an
ops team and you have a lot of habits
you have a lot of things you're
accepting and it's it can be very
dangerous for us where to take a very
adversarial stance as Andrew mentioned
from day one as opposed to sort of
sitting down and working out some new
relationships and then having some
agreements that hey when things go off
the rails we're going to talk about it
we're gonna fix it I had one other thing
I was going to say
what was it I can actually ask you
specifically to experience because when
he was trying to GCPs re-do Deb's were
already there right so we you you
brought in the s Therese is there any
specific things that you did to make
sure that the essays in devs change it
very slightly which is that we actually
hired a lot of GCP has grown so
incredibly fast thank you all for buying
it that we have hired a large number of
executives from outside Google so in
areas of Google that have grown more
slowly it's a very organic
you know the VP's kind of get beaten
into shape by their peers and they
cooperate a little bit more of essary
that is less true in GCP and I like my
job for a while was literally educator
of VPS and there's like this this buy
kind of class of VPS and I taught all of
them one of the key things that that we
have though in our toolbox at Google
that I think isn't always common outside
that helps with this adversarial
relationship is the ability to politely
and calmly walk away they handing back
of the pager and that's something that I
get people asking me like I'll go into
customer meetings and you know like the
head of ops I'll pull me aside to go no
really can you actually do that like
have you and like yeah actually not me
personally but I have had a conversation
with devs I've had one conversation
where he said your service is bad and I
am losing
and I'm not going to block their
transfer when this team gets too low
we're going to have no choice would you
like to change course now but spoiler
they did and I've had other teams where
we've sat down and we've had like months
long conversation of is this a healthy
relationship is this something we should
continue and the thing is that having
that position to take is both a relief
valve through Surrey because you don't
need to drive it to the point of
adversity honest but it's also a really
good sort of early warning discussion
with your devs and but to have that you
need a culture where it's okay for devs
to be on call and that is a very hard
conversation in some companies depending
where you come from that's either
natural or incredibly insane feel free
to tell them that at Google all the devs
even the ones with s arrays are actually
expected to be able to be on call yep
so we do we do to share it on call like
most of my teams the devs will answer
pages during the day and s3 takes them
overnight and after hours so you know
you can use my name because often like
who doesn't know we do yeah but like you
need those escape valves because at the
end of the day as much as we want to say
partnership just like how QA tends to
get the short end of the stick because
they render the end of the development
cycle as sory can very easily get the
short end the stick if you have not put
in some rails to help with the power
imbalance may i underscore this
particularly phenomenon
it is of course that that exercise to
you as to how this may or may not apply
at your own company let's let's just say
that there are about 80,000 60,000
engine your shape to people there are
twenty eight hundred and eighty six as
of yesterday a series at the company so
that's a thing about that ratio right to
point mumble to sixty so essary are
scarce resource we're really hard to
hire for that also means we go where the
action is and so working backwards from
that at Google most software engineers
on most projects that are not search ads
chrome absence cetera where the cream of
the crop revenue wise the veil of GCP
right GCP forgive me sorry most things
that launched at Google never get a
necessary most things that launched at
Google that do be necessary don't get an
SRE team mind you a like two continents
men we have six people in each team
necessary team some of them it will take
orders for years and so by the time SOE
gets to the regular stable on Corvette
golly gosh it's a really low
maintainable system because the people
who were in charge of adding features
and potentially operational burden to it
have had to deal with it it's so on the
flip side right I need to use the word
leverage because it sounds like I'm
spouting out some Harvard Business
Review nonsense but but the real
leverage here is if your apps team
already has a hundred percent of the on
call where can they go from there like
and that maybe you let a lot of people
are thinking here here's a real quick
one maybe not all new launches abruptly
but like the mid-tier oil and tail
launches don't have a series on them and
that's not meant to be punitive that's
meant to be we're focusing this again at
the risk of mysticism more like a
surreal this weird thing that know if
that's bad too
necessarily being attached to a project
being they are we're here to help this
is a sign of focus this is a sign of
enthusiasm of skill above and beyond
that is necessary so you want to work
the best arrays as opposed to I wanna
add one more project that's one more
projects we toad says as we add more
pages to the ops team like that's so
incredibly different and you can iterate
towards that while maintaining that
leverage respect scarcity and if you're
thinking about that I did see enough
nods that I was gonna do this quick
follow-up realize that the deeper in
your stack something is paradoxically
the more important is dev sra on it your
leaf node the stuff that your customers
actually interact with that's probably
pretty simple stuff and when it goes
down it doesn't affect other things your
your database your pub/sub services your
everything else in that big
infrastructure layer that's where the
danger is because the blast radius when
those things go out and the complexity
when those things grab is much higher so
a good place to start is where your if
you have a devs launching a new service
or a new feature that's
adoption that is a good place to say hey
you know why don't you guys support that
until it gets big and we're happy to
help you we're happy to figure out you
know how to improve it
what monitoring you need but what do you
guys handle it at the start so we talked
about how the relationship of essays and
devs are and we also start talking about
how the relationship of SRS and the
business owners of the product team
because they are at the ones actually
going to decide where their saris are
going is that right so the question is
towards how should a serine relate with
product designers as opposed to maybe
feature engineering designers right so
which how do you how is the relationship
between the teams that need necessaries
and how do they request that to the
private team ah yes so that that is one
of the other things that we do because
as as indra said we don't want esterase
to be so it turns out the way humans
work is that if I give you something for
free you do not care at all about it and
if I charge you a penny you suddenly
care way more than one Penny's worth and
so we actually treat s3 similarly when
you're looking at your head count your
head count as a VP is the sum of the
Esther days on your product plus your
engineers s3's come out of the same pool
so if you're not willing to staff s
arena up Esther day will not take on
your service but when you do that counts
against your product and that puts your
skin in the game and that makes you like
you are literally and deliberately
trading off engineers software engineers
for help myself software engineers for
Suri's very deliberately and while at
Google we do report through a separate
management chains that we have the
ability desk laden to say no which we
also think is critical but like that's a
very tight partnership and what part of
your question did I miss maybe
yeah I mean I think the the mutual
exclusivity of staffing right what do
you mean I'm noting down the depth to
get an S area if only it was fungible
like that
is actually really I think important s
re should be doing work that s eries
uniquely can do the best so if your s
Ariza writing features for your dev
product that's not something s Therese
can uniquely do the best the idea is
that your staffing appropriately so your
SRE team is the size to get the most out
of that and if you actually move that
back in the dev team you probably have
to put more people on it but
simultaneously if you put too much
headcount to t that Suri team such that
they're flowing over in writing dev
features they're gonna be less efficient
at it because that's not their
specialization that's not their passion
though that means said encouraging
cross-pollination and rotations like
only able to say I am the grand
you know dollar sign company I I hereby
pre-authorize that you know anyone with
the quarters notice can spend six months
going to either team from either team in
order to build empathy shocking right
and and read amazing we actually
financially incentivize our devs to
spend six months with sree and it's
brilliant and an awfully large number of
them convert this very more than fifty
percent so it's billed as a catch and
release program but it's actually more
of a Hotel California which is great so
for an all your talk it seems like sa
he's not only taking the pager and
McCain monitors it's there's a lot of
culture related to that and then you
have an interesting title is like SRA
culture late what does that mean what is
the necessary culturing folks but I'm
about to find out
so I spent 12 years on call for all the
different facets of Google search which
is a fascinating and wild ride and then
for the co-current with that for the
last four years up until basically a
month ago I was also the co-founder and
a pretty significant designer of a lot
of the orientation programs for all new
s eries so I've done the hiring I've
done the training I've done the like
panicked one-on-ones in the night career
existential angst I've done it all with
many people in the asari organization
and I think ester has a lot of s re as a
concept and Google essary as it is
applied has some really fascinating
things to it I think there's things we
do really well but there are now like
in our company there are 240 something
every to use divided by 2 has repaired
over continents that's a lot of
different ways of rolling the dice and
trying out different ways of doing
things even just things like weekly
disaster drills or you know how every
single dev every partnership is designed
like I can give you an answer and it
might be representative but the chances
are there's a lot of variance so I'm
actually going around and visiting teams
one week at a time to cross-pollinate a
lot of this stuff I think a lot of it is
to me to simplify the essary
personality I won't because there are
multiple personalities but the set of
personalities is visit us the ability to
circumvent hierarchy in order to put the
user first that sounds like a lot of
corpus speak let me try this again and
realizing where the rubber meets the
road that you may be the most decisive
person in the room and then encouraging
people to take that on like case in
point what I have told every single you
necessary that has started at our
company is when you're on call
you get paged you are hereby officially
VP worth of authority for your product
in the moments because don't worry it's
only several thousand dollars a second
right like we give you great
responsibility and Trust essary is a
mesh not a tree when it comes to solving
our systems because our systems are
distributed systems or just our systems
aren't when you hear boss on the point
of your boss on the point of your boss
trees right no offense
so we need folks who can think like a
mesh it all kind of comes into that so I
think our culture is trust each other
support each other it's not all hands
and kumbaya but it is its radial it's
mesh it's not a tree of technologically
and people wise I want to expand on that
just a little bit Andrew as always is
spot-on and I have little to say but to
come when I was considering coming to
Google I had a friend who is the
director of all of our network and
traffic stuff everything I was utterly
amazed that he went on call and utterly
terrified of the prospect and could not
believe it thought he was like God among
men and I started at Google and I went
through one of the very early essary to
use which is what I didn't damage you
and I saw the level of support the level
of tool in the level of camaraderie in
the level of trust and acceptance and I
told him I had no more respect for him
anymore because they saw how much help
he had but it actually took a lot of the
scary and the mystery out of it and one
of the things I value most about s3 at
Google because I work with a lot of dev
teams we are probably one of the most
diverse orgs I work with and I think
that's because to work here you have to
be open to new ideas to work in essary
you have to be open to new ideas to
different ways of thinking and you have
to be able to support each other and
work together
blameless post-mortems only work when
you can actually pull off blameless with
a straight face Amina and to have a
culture to enforce that kind of thing
like you you really need to keep on it
and to not tolerate people who are going
to perturb that like you need to be much
much more careful caretakers of not
hiring jerks of getting rid of people
who can't work with people like them
because this is a high-stress role once
in a while and then you know you're not
on call again but like every moment of
on call could explode into google.com is
down and no one wants to be the reason
that searches down
although andrew didn't you take search
down once I did
as my team had brought a bag of did you
know for $100 you can get a shredded d--
circulated pile of a hundred thousand US
dollars from the treasury department and
my team once alerted me with a a bag of
shredded money it had post-it note on it
with the location of the cluster that I
had worked rather considerably and that
was remaining I was one of the cool kids
because I wrote the post mortem we found
out some really interesting things about
the actions that I did in there
ramifications thereof that we now use as
part of our proper reactive procedures
right I was like maybe this'll work BAM
hey we made it worse but now we know
right and that would never have happened
on many other types of dev and IT ops
type of relationships think about the
type of environment you need to build
for that to be actually true -
everyone's corner that to me is what sre
culture is and that's that's the only
way you can survive because if you have
if you have Heidi if you have finger
pointing if you have jerks on your team
that's gonna come out sometime and hit
prod and you'll take it out on your dubs
in the same way you'll just stop
projecting right yeah so I have only one
more question before we open the mic so
please prepare your questions and maybe
the challenge one but how do you define
success of an SRE team I had a really
good answer for this like 44 minutes ago
well I want to underscore a point
around if you were to release the
headcount behind the f13 back to the
sweet iime that it would the software
engineer team that he would take there's
a sense of we are working on the most
important things that the hot gooey
center of our product right we are we
are we are at the interface of the
system and the user and it's how many
people have seen Tron right that's Tron
they fight for the user like that's our
a Tron very similar other managers have
a little bit more quantitative answer
but but you can pick from between us for
me it's that your your s ellos if you
don't know what an SLO is please talk to
someone from Siri that your SLO is
actually our user centric that us those
actually reflect the user experience not
what you're able to measure not what was
easy that your team is spending at least
half their time doing enduring work that
doesn't necessarily mean writing code
but it means you're doing work that is
going to continue to provide value at
least six months into the future that's
my best definition of engineering work
that I can come up with I think it's
really critical that like you know
you're not just patching things and
calling it code look look it's not toil
because I will code well if it's
throwaway work it's still not enduring
and that you have an appropriate
relationship with your dev team it is
possible to be too chummy with your dev
team I have seen AI if you guys know the
phrase captured regulators but I've seen
s eries who will bend over backwards to
justify ignoring the fact that they went
out of error budget because they are
they have forgotten that part of their
job is I like to describe it as you're
the insurance policy that you took out
for yourself for the future when you
were about to make a bad decision and
that's what things like error budgets
and SRA help for is we say hey you know
in the columns we all agreed we would
freeze in this situation and
now we really want to get this release
out we know the customers want it we're
out of our budget and in and it won't
where the customers think do they
actually value this more than the risk
of additional outages and so it is is
very easy for us Ares to get caught up
in that because they do you want a good
relationship here the dev team but you
also need to have us a foot outside the
role at the same time and obviously you
know bad would be being the other way to
this point another thought exercise
right I talked about scarcity like to me
the successful I story team is that is
the essary team that every dev team
wishes they could work with not because
it's here's a black hole I can throw my
pages into haha because in that case you
know if you were to say that your
company gathering raise your hand if you
want an s3 team and if everyone raises
their hand and Snickers a little bit you
know that's not good so so here's an
exercise right maybe this will work for
you maybe want to do dev teams ask if
you have an s3 team that you were
working well what would you work on
together right and if the answer is all
the bad stuff and right like it's this
interface to apply for the honor of
being able to work with a necessary team
it's the weirdest of things right it's
it's again to the consumer electronics
marketing technique of a one-cent cost
so much more than zero cents but then
also on the flip side right and take all
of the answers to this ingestion survey
and take it to your fledgling us Surry
team and say which of these answers do
you think is actually right and if the
s3 team and says oh the ones that said
we get to work on tickets all day
yeah right that's also bad right it
should probably be somewhere in the
middle where if you as the arbiter of
who gets to work and gets staffed to
what says I can see them we want to
remove
to the right sets of matches where the
essary team says we want to extend and
make this product launch and faster you
know we want to stay up less bless it
and light for all of us and if the dev
team says we really like to get some
that some hard critique of our systems
so that we don't launch in a fiery ball
of doom later like all of that is good
but you can imagine the cross-product of
all of the bad maybe try that out see
what happens
can I add one thing that's not what you
asked of course ok this is something I
want to make sure I say and I think just
in case it doesn't come up into a
question I'm not a big fan of
methodologies that require 100%
adherence to be true so any kind of
purity tests or whatever that and I have
heard when talking with people soon as
people seen the SRA book as essentially
a purity test you have to do all of
these things in this er you're not an
SRA and I love the story that I will
tell it I usually don't tell to anywhere
near this large and audience of a no six
engineer who showed up at stand up one
day right after the SRA book was
released no six meeting relatively
senior I'm sorry staff engineer yeah
like one level above senior and he shows
up with the SRA book in hand and he says
hey guys I read this really cool book
over the weekend maybe we should do some
things in it even at Google
every team doesn't do everything and we
do things different ways and we pick and
we choose what's important to us and
what's important to our service the kind
of one sort of central tenant that I see
about sre is the understanding of
incentives and the understanding of the
value of engineering if you're
understanding how you and your dev team
have aligned incentives and you're
making agreements ahead of time whatever
those aren't and if you're making sure
that your team is doing engineering work
all of the rest are things that you may
use to get into that place or to get
better but please don't think that if
you're not doing wheel of misfortune
you're not doing SRE
or if you don't have actually the Siri
folks would probably tell you that error
budgets and SL O's have to be on that
list
yeah I'm getting lots about some CRA all
right add that to the third one but
thank you David
but like you don't have to do everything
you don't have to do everything from the
start and pick and choose what works for
you and your company culture like it's
it's a cool area this is this is
something unlike anything else we do and
it's an opportunity for those of us who
love infrastructure who love the stuff
around software to be able to have this
as a career and it's a very exciting
time and the word asymptotic really
applies here but you want to make a
large leap away from a traditional or
stale or practice of ten years ago type
situation of devs and ops you want to
make a large straw a very strong foray
into that and then ease off and ease off
and ease off as you get closer to some
sort of theoretical limit many companies
have talked to said we're gonna try like
a very little thing and see how that
works I'm gonna be the only person here
is going to tell you that's not going to
work anyway I can talk to us more about
this and move the first it is free like
if you just say we're just gonna make
this one real incremental thing it's not
going to work and you're wasting your
time okay so I'll be the bad cop here
and but now for everyone here who was
nice cop and would love to tell you more
about
can work together to do this because I'm
sure you have lots of questions and
we're going to answer a lot of up here
on stage but for the extra ones after
this menu please raise your hand if you
are crüe or you're a died in the world
Google essary here we would love to
answer questions look around and find
the face of the next person with their
hand raised
[Music]